the Trump administration can provide
enough kovin 19 tests for at least 2% of
each state's residents according to a
senior official these masks are becoming
a must-have accessory for air travel and
Detroit car makers are targeting May
18th to resume some production at their
US factories
I'm Shelby Holiday and here are today's
headlines from The Wall Street Journal
we have enough testing to begin
reopening and the reopening process the
White House released what it called a
blueprint of its testing plans the
administration said it would send all 50
states enough tests to screen at least
two percent of residents in separate
statements retailers including Walmart
and CBS announced that they were ramping
up their capacity to offer self swab
tests health experts say testing will
still need to be expanded further to
quickly identify and isolate cases and
move out of lockdown safely several
states have already started easing
restrictions on Monday the governor of
Texas said the stay at home order would
end Thursday airlines are starting to
require or encourage passengers to wear
face masks from check-in to disembarking
JetBlue will require customers to wear
masks starting May 4th and American said
it would start handing out masks at
boarding next month demand for air
travel has collapsed with domestic
flights only 12 and a half percent full
on average according to an industry
trade group carriers are looking for
ways to protect their staff and make
travelers comfortable with the idea of
boarding planes again other measures
include keeping people apart and
eliminating food and beverage service
Detroit automakers including General
Motors Ford and Fiat Chrysler will
tentatively resume some production at
their u.s. factories on May 18th
that's according to people familiar with
their plans the companies which shut
down u.s. factories in March are working
out security protocols with United Auto
Workers leaders they have said they will
provide protective gear for workers when
they return and will try to maintain
social distancing protocols in their
plants
a Ford spokeswoman said the company
hasn't decided when to restart North
American factories foreign automakers
with non unionized work forces have
plans to resume production sooner